[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología y debido a la
situación que vivimos a causa de la
pandemia de kobe 19 nos adaptamos desde
nuestros hogares para llevarles toda la
información
-soy valentina torres sánchez gracias
por acompañarme en esta ocasión
iniciamos en japón alguna vez se han
preguntado qué tan lejos pueden llegar
las partículas de saliva al hablar
cantar o toser esta respuesta nos la dan
los científicos del instituto rica en
kobe con estas animaciones así se
expanden cuando alguien habla sin
mascarilla así cuando alguien canta
fuerte
y así cuando alguien tose dos veces
con respecto al virus la gente en el
mundo puede estar ciegamente asustada o
subestimar esto sin fundamentos
cuando pensé en por qué ocurre esto dije
porque no lo puedes ver con los ojos
entonces la gente desconfían y vienen a
dedicar a minas y muestras de forma
visual como el virus puede expandirse
tal vez sea una oportunidad para que la
gente reflexione sobre su propio riesgo
y piensa específicamente en qué medidas
tomar
hingis en su estudio los investigadores
también mostraron cómo se dispersan las
partículas de saliva cuando una persona
está sentada frente a otra sin usar un
tapabocas esto es lo que ocurre a una
distancia de 80 centímetros a un metro
y a 1.2 metros
no queremos decir que es obligatorio
usar mascarilla pero sí pueden usen la y
cuando se usa solamente una pantalla o
visor se aumenta el riesgo de infección
es importante estar enterados de cuál es
el riesgo y usar los elementos
adecuadamente de orituco de concepto y
cultura de ánimas cada vez está más
extendido el uso de los tapabocas lo que
ha llevado que se incorporen diferentes
tecnologías en estos instrumentos en
japon ingenieros de la empresa emergente
donets robotics desarrollaron una
mascarilla de alta tecnología llamada sy
face está hecha de plástico blanco y
silicona tiene un micrófono integrado
que se conecta al teléfono inteligente
del usuario a través de bluetooth y
cuenta con amplificador y un sistema que
puede transcribir y traducir / japonés
chino coreano vietnamita indonesio
inglés español y francés cabe aclarar
que está diseñada para ser usada con un
tapabocas convencional al mismo tiempo
todo son de modo acto
el yerno desarrollamos este producto
para llenar el vacío entre trabajar
remotamente y comunicarse cara a cara
pese al coronavirus algunas veces
tenemos que encontrarnos directamente
con alguien este producto nos permite
hablar directamente manteniendo una
distancia de 2 metros
cambiamos de país porque en singapur fue
desarrollada una mascarilla con sensores
que monitorea la temperatura corporal el
pulso la presión sanguínea y los niveles
de oxígeno en la sangre
todo ello es transmitido vía bluetooth a
un teléfono inteligente los responsables
de este invento señalan que podría
proteger a los trabajadores sanitarios
que deben tomar los signos vitales de
las personas cuando llegan a los centros
de salud
de este virus
esperamos que esto se pueda usar como un
simple indicador de los signos tempranos
de alerta de un contagio y seremos
capaces de advertirle a la gente que
vaya y vea un médico para que le hagan
una prueba con un hisopo o los chequeos
adecuados
porque la propuesta
y los trabajadores sanitarios estarán
expuestos a pacientes cuando les tomen
los signos vitales esto representa un
riesgo para ellos
[Música]
y vamos a finalizar este espacio fuera
de la tierra en la luna porque es
científicos de la nasa confirmaron que
detectaron presencia de moléculas de
agua en varios cráteres de ese satélite
natural
no esperábamos agua no suponíamos que el
agua pudiera sobrevivir en la parte de
la luna que el sol ilumina así que queda
la pregunta de cómo llegó allí y cómo
sobrevivió
es una cuestión científica interesante
que nos cuenta algo de la historia de la
luna podría contarnos sobre procesos que
han ocurrido en otros cuerpos sin aire
de nuestro sistema solar los hallazgos
fueron realizados en la superficie
iluminada de la luna con ayuda del
observatorio estratosférico de
astronomía infrarroja conocido como
sofía la accesibilidad y la
disponibilidad siempre serán un problema
todavía no sabemos cómo extraer el agua
de la luna es por eso que enviamos
primero instrumentos robóticos para que
los sigan los primeros humanos
son los primeros humanos harán
experimentos científicos para descubrir
qué tan accesible es el agua lunar no
vivirán del agua de los primeros
exploradores que regresen a la luna los
expertos de la nasa indicaron que aún
faltan muchos datos por conocer sobre el
agua hallada en la luna principalmente
determinar si el líquido está disponible
y se puede extraer pues uno de los
planes de la agencia es establecer una
base permanente en ese satélite si el
líquido es accesible podría llegar a
transformarse en oxígeno e incluso en
combustible lo que le facilitaría mucho
sus misiones a los astronautas así
concluimos esta crónica cuídense si es
posible quédense en casa recuerden que
la salud es lo más importante gracias
por su compañía y continúen con más en
france 24 y france24 puntocom
más